[Musique]
et nous sommes dans l'entrepôt de sos
accessoires avec son fondateur olivier
de montlivault bonjour bonjour
[Musique]
alors ils sont et ses accessoires c'est
près de 20 millions d'euros de chiffre
d'affaires en 2021 c'est environ 5000
commandes de produits de pièces
détachées par jour c'est ça mais chaque
jour nous vivrons près de 5000 commandes
de pièces détachées électroménager à
destination des consommateurs des à des
particuliers pour leur permettre
justement de réparer leur lave linge
leurs fours leur frigo leurs micros le
leur à leur aspirateur c'est une
sociétés que j'ai fondées donc il ya
treize ans maintenant après avoir
travaillé dizaine d'années chez
l'artiste leader de l'électroménager en
france et je me s'élabore dans la
centrale d'achat accessoires et pièces
détachées c'est clairement la main que
j'ai identifié un besoin suffisamment
satisfaits pour tous les consommateurs
dans toutes les enseignes à d'ailleurs
arriver à trouver une pièce détachée ou
un accessoire pour entretenir ou réparer
son appareil électroménager et à
l'époque je me suis dit ce ne sont que
des produits de besançon ne sont que des
produits de contraintes il ya peu de
plaisir à aller chercher en magasin donc
le canal internet un canal fantastique
pour distribuer il répondre à ces
besoins consommateurs donc c'est partant
de cette expérience que j'ai dessiné
décidé de franchir le pas
d'entrepreneuriat et que j'ai lancé à
sauver ses accesseurs et puis là on le
voit un autre projet énorme c'est
combien de mètres carrés ici donc là
nous sommes à 2500 mètres carrés mais
vous voyez on est dans un espace qui est
de plus en plus contraints et nous
allons déménager dans dans quelques mois
dans un site près de quatre fois plus
grande en au printemps prochain on va en
parler on va détailler justement votre
stratégie mais d'abord pourquoi les
pièces détachées sont essentielles
aujourd'hui pourquoi aussi focalisé sur
l'auto réparation alors finalement vous
aider les clients à réparer eux-mêmes
leurs produits 17 exactement ça au
départ je dirais une autre notre marché
le marché auquel nous dressions c'était
vraiment ce que j'appelle les les
personnes les plus bricoleurs c'était ça
les débuts de sos accessoires c'était
vraiment vendre des accessoires et
surtout des pièces détachées technique à
ce que j'appelle les super bricoler mais
notre but a vraiment été
particulièrement ses 106 dernières
années de démocratiser l'auto réparation
en proposant à tout un chacun un maximum
de coups et de services pour les aider à
franchir le pas deux lotos réparation et
de surtout à la réussir parce que dans
la plupart des cas c'est assez simple
quand on a la bonne information et la
bonne assistance et c'est comme ça que
le modèle de sos accessoires a fortement
évolué et que nous sommes devenus des
leaders en france par internet de loto
réparation et de vente de pièces
détachées aux particuliers un leader qui
a levé 10 millions d'euros en 2021 lever
110 millions d'euros quelle est votre
stratégie avec à travers ce fonds que
vous avez obtenus et que vous allez
pouvoir investir que je suppose dans
l'année 2010 on a déjà commencé en effet
à investir vous avez à vous avez raison
nous avons réalisé donc la plus
importante levée de fonds du secteur au
printemps au printemps dernier dans nos
ambitions sont multiples elles sont
évidemment logistique il faut faire face
à ces volumes croissants
elles sont également commerciale en
france en développant tous nos outils et
nos services d'assistance à la
réparation les tutos les vidéos on en a
parlé vous allez les présenter plus
longuement je crois tout à l'heure les
services d'assistance en ligne notamment
de deux visions et un développement à
l'international puisque notre modèle
évidemment et en partie duplicable sur
les pays qui jouxte qui jouxte la france
puisque la plupart des appareils sont
communs aux marchés français allemand
italien espagnol yo tôt et on prévoit un
déménagement sur un site près de quatre
fois plus grand au printemps prochain à
bord pas vous êtes tous nos
collaborateurs aujourd'hui nous sommes
70 aujourd'hui sur le sur le site qui se
répartissent pour moitié sur la
logistique vous le voyez il ya du monde
qui travaillent qui travaillent ici et
35 dans les bureaux et ce qui est
incroyable ici c'est que c'est vraiment
le mariage si je puis dire des métiers
les plus traditionnels avec les métiers
les plus récents les plus geeks les plus
sains les plus techniques ici chez se
laisse accessoires vous avez des
techniciens électroménager chevronné
vous avez des magasiniers mais vous avez
également des dates analystes des
développeurs
un web des rois
du web du web marketing qui nous
permettent justement de proposer de
manière moderne ce service qui somme
toute est vieux comme le monde la
réparation ou l'aide à la réparation
merci olivier de mon niveau merci à vous
rappelle que vous êtes le fondateur de
cette société donc et soes accessoires
et puis maintenant je crois qu'il ya un
fil tauriel qui est en cours de tournage
l'art justement je vous montre
nous avons rejoint le studio de sos
accessoires l'endroit où sont réalisés
les tutoriels est avec nous le hic le
goff bonjour bonjour
technicien électro ménager un espace que
vous partagez avec martin le cadreur
monteur de ces vidéos alors est ce que
vous nous expliquer votre quotidien ici
or le but est de justement monter des
vidéos afin d'aider au maximum les gens
dans l'auto réparation
afin d'acquérir une certaine autonomie
et
par le biais d'autres d'autres supports
on est donc on les aide au quotidien là
vous étiez en train de réaliser une
vidéo c'était quoi alors ces cinq
astuces justement pour prolonger la
durée de vie de son appareil en
l'occurrence actuellement on travaille
sur les lave vaisselle comment ça se
passe en fait c'est vous qui écrivez vos
textes ses dépenses réalisées alors
principalement oui c'est moi qui écrit
les textes mais de temps en temps il
m'arrive de demander de l'aide à martin
à marie ou à mes collègues qui
travaillent au service technique de de
travailler aussi dessus ça c'est une
partie de votre activité parce que vous
êtes aussi dans l'espace service
après-vente en quelque sorte oui c'est
ça on fait des vidéos mais aussi on fait
des tutos des tutos écrit d'études des
réponses aux appels téléphoniques
par visio et tout autre support comme
mais il presta et autres pour justement
aider nos clients à s'auto répare les
dernières questions eric quel sens vous
donnez à votre activité au quotidien
c'est rendre service et ça oui c'est une
chose que j'ai découvert au fil des au
fil des années en grandissant que jamais
j'ai aimé ce côté de rendre service est
vraiment d'aider les gens à s'auto
réparer c'est devenu une vraie passion
merci aux métiers merci le week end of
mercy et je vous propose tout de suite
de regarder un extrait de vos
prestations
[Musique]
bonjour à tous je sui loïc de chez sos
accessoires si vous constatez sur les
programmes à chaleur tournante que les
listes ne tourne plus que votre four
chauffe mal ou que celui-ci est bruyant
c'est que vous avez peut-être un
problème avec le moteur ventilateur de
chaleur tournante